so today I want to show you something
pretty cool on how to make some slight
changes in your breath your breathing to
help you lower cortisol and pull
yourself out of a stress strength
anxiety and even a panic attack now you
can also use this if you have asthma or
if you're just not able to sleep I use
this technique every single night before
I go to bed to just put myself into a
deep sleep pretty fast all right so this
entire topic revolves around one muscle
called the diaphragm which is a
fascinating muscle the diaphragm is the
only skeletal muscle that has both
involuntary and voluntary function in
other words it can run automatically
without you even thinking about it
that's called involuntary and you can
also control your breathing so you can
bypass this involuntary mechanism all
right so this diaphragm it's right
underneath your lungs and if you ever
look at that what happens with the
diaphragm it acts like a parachute so
when it contracts the parachute goes
down and it pulls oxygen into the lungs
and they expand and then when it
releases and relaxes passively you can
actively relax it and then the pressure
of your lungs once you get this oxygen
in will release mostly passively and
allow CO2 to exit your body a lot of
times people when they think about
stress they think about needing more
oxygen but you really don't need more
oxygen when you are in stress you need a
balance of that CO2 and oxygen to allow
oxygen into the cells the CO2 is needed
so let's say for example you have
someone in a panic attack right what are
they doing they're hyperventilating
they're getting a lot of oxygen with
very little CO2 so what can they do to
pull themselves out of that state they
can breathe in a paper bag to get more
CO2 which can help the absorption of
oxygen so it's not just about increasing
oxygen it's about putting in this
balance of oxygen and CO2 now the
diaphragm which is right underneath your
lungs is a very ignored muscle it's so
important because it works 24 7. it
can't take a break it works constantly
you deliver oxygen in the body and get
rid of the skin to balance that
statement and so it has to work when you
exercise when you're sleeping it has to
work constantly by the way when you do
exercise and you push yourself you might
feel like side pain on the side of your
your rib cage that is the diaphragm uh
cramping and so if you're not used to
that level of exercise it can definitely
be an issue and it can actually stop you
from exercising because it can go into a
cramp also hiccups are related to a
diaphragm problem this is why for
example hiccups are triggered by stress
and so stress can affect the nerve
signals that can create this
inappropriate signaling to the diaphragm
which can then cause this irregular
pickup effect now the diaphragm is 100
controlled by a nerve it's called the
phrenic nerve and you have two of them
the one on this right side though does
also innervate the gallbladder and the
outside of your liver the liver capsule
now there are some mixed reviews as far
as whether it innervates the gallbladder
and the liver or not I think it does
because if you have pressure within the
bile ducts if you have pressure within
the gallbladder if you have pressure
within the liver you're going to get
this referred pain from the phrenic
nerve that goes up to the right side of
your nectar here it can go to your right
trap it can wrap around to the rhomboid
area right through here so anything
right here is usually the phrenic nerve
being referred from down in the
gallbladder so just from a treatment
standpoint if you have right shoulder
pain and you get treated for this area
and you don't get relief that's because
it's being referred from down in the
gallbladder area chances are you ate
something that you shouldn't have eaten
or you overrate something that you
should be eating you just eat too much
and you're getting bloating so there's
other things that can affect this nerve
other than just being in stress for
example you can have gallbladder
problems you can have gallstones you can
have bile sludge you can be a diabetic
and have this condition called diabetic
neuropathy which affects the phrenic
nerve in which case the remedy for that
is mean okay so just make another note
if you are a diabetic and you have that
problem and relating to the gallbladder
the antidote the real simple solution is
to take something called taka to help
you thin the bile and that it's sort of
that referred pain pretty quick okay
another condition that can affect this
nerve is a hernia there's a weakness
within the collagen tissue that
separates and it's bulging up into the
stomach area and so that can put
pressure on the phrenic nerve as well
but I think out of all the things that
can affect breathing in the critic nerve
bloating is at the top of the list you
also have another thing called gastric
bypasser surgery that can affect the
phrenic nerve in fact 20 percent of
everyone who gets that surgery has a
problem with the phrenic nerve and they
have pain to the right side so that
being said how does one lower cortisol
by changing their breath pattern what
you do is you actively take over this
automatic system and so you start
putting control in and start regulating
the pattern of breathing anytime you're
in this sympathetic flight or flight
State the typical breathing is not going
to be a balanced inhalation in
exhalation it's usually going to be like
this
it's a short exhalation the inhalation
is going to be longer than the
exhalation so this simple solution is
just to balance out your breathing so
the first thing I'm going to recommend
you can use this throughout the day like
just do it five minutes before you go to
bed do it five minutes through the day
you know if you're stressed you want to
breathe to the nose okay and you want to
breathe in for four seconds okay and you
want to breathe out for four seconds
just balance your breathing and I
recommend you breathe to your diaphragm
and the way you do that is you put your
hand on your stomach
and you push out the stomach as you
allow the diaphragm to pull the air in
okay I mean you can breathe through your
chest
but I recommend you bring to your
stomach because it's just going to be
less stress on your body
so let me demonstrate
now you couldn't see that but I
basically counted in four seconds in in
four seconds out if you did that for one
to five minutes you would feel very very
relaxed I recommend you do it while
you're driving I recommend that you do
it if you're walking in nature through
the day just for five minutes it will
greatly help pull you out of stress and
reduce your cortisol levels now there's
something else you can do to take it to
the next level and this is really good
if you're in a major stress State okay
so what you're going to do is you're
going to keep your inhalation constant
like four seconds but you're going to
increase the time of which you exhale
okay so you'll breathe in for four
seconds
and you'll breathe out for like seven or
eight seconds now what is that gonna do
it's going to stimulate a part of the
nervous system called the
parasympathetic nervous system and that
is a system that reduces adrenaline it
helps reduce cortisol that is a system
that helps you go into the deep Delta
wave sleep and so you're bypassing this
automaticity of the suprenic nerve and
you yourself are now in the broad
receipt and you're switching from the
sympathetic mode to the parasympathetic
mode so in one of the studies there was
a significant decrease in cortisol
levels after 45 minutes of using these
breathing exercises and they mentioned
that cortisol is a hormone that can be
easily affected by your breathing and I
listed in the description other studies
that shows that when you do these
breathing exercises your cortisol levels
will go down and here's another study
using deep in slow breathing techniques
to reduce anxiety and vagal outflow
that's the vagus nerve the vagus nerve
is responsible for something called the
parasympathetic activity in the body
that's the system that helps you relax
helps you sleep and helps you digest and
here's another study uh called the
effect of diaphragmatic breathing that's
breathing to your diaphragm on attention
negative effect and stress in healthy
adults so in this study they compared uh
people who did the breathing exercises
to people who did not and there was a
significant lowering of cortisol after
these breathing exercises compared to no
changes in cortisol levels in the other
group and so they concluded that when
you breathe with your diaphragm you will
improve sustained attention as well as
lowering your cortisol levels and I want
you just to do this breathing exercise
for a couple minutes and then I want you
to comment down below of what you
experience but you've never done this
before I think you'll notice a pretty
big change in your stress level go ahead
and try it now and if you haven't seen
my video on panic attacks you have to
check that out right now because I go
into a little bit more on the details of
why it's so important to increase your
CO2 to absorb oxygen I put that video up
right here check it out